كشف انسحاب قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
احياء شمال مدينه غزه يوم امس الاثنين عن
دمار واسع في تلك الاحياء وجثث واشلاء
متناثره هناك الصحفي جهاد ابو شنب زار
منطقه المقوسي وابراج الفيروز وشارع دوار
دبيه وعاد لنا بهذا
التقرير نحن الان في منطقه الشاطئ الشمالي
شارع دوار ضربيه بعد انسحاب قوات الاحتلال
من المنطقه التي ظلت تتواجد فيها قوات
الاحتلال طيله العمليه البريه انسحبت صباح
اليوم هذا هو نادي الصداقه
الرياضي هذا هو شارع دوار درابيه كما نرى
الدمار في كل مكان في هذه المنطقه تجريف
وخراب ودمار وحرق للمنازل
والمساجد لم يبقى شيء الا وتم تدميره
حتى المدارس لم تسلم كل شيء تم قصفه
وتدميره بالكامل هنا دمار كبير جدا اثمه
ناريه اصابت هذه المناطق في بدايه العمليه
البريه كان من المفترض ان تكون امامنا في
هذه الصوره ابراج المخابرات حيث تم قصفها
بالكامل هذه هي ابراج الفيروز او ما تبقى
من ابراج الفيروز هي سلسله ابراج كبيره
كانت ربما تعتبر مدينه سكنيه صغيره لم
يتبقى منها شيء منذ الصباح والمواطنين
ايضا ينتشلون جسس شهداء كانت ملقاه في
الشوارع في هذه
المناطق اشلاء الشهداء مبعثره في المنطقه
مشهد مروع
للغايه شهداء اشلاء ممزقه على الارض
الاشلاء في كل مكان الشهداء في كل مكان
هنا مواطنين كان كانوا يحاولون استخراج
بعض اغراضهم ومحتوياته من ما تبقى من
منازلهم تم قصفهم بشكل جنوني كما نرى شهيد
ملقى على الارض لم يجد من يدفنه او يتم
انتشاله حتى الان حجم الجريمه كبير جدا في
هذه المنطقه بالتحديد في مدينه
غزه حيث كانت تتواجد قوات الاحتلال طيله
فتره العمليه البريه في هذه المناطق
انسحبت فقط صباح
اليوم حيث استطاع المواطنين كما نسمع يتم
اطلاق النار والقذائف
القذائف والرصاص مازال مستمرا في هذه
المناطق حتى
الان
كل
المدارس في هذه المنطقه تم تدميرها
بالكامل هذه المدارس جزء منها يتبع الى
الحكومه الفلسطينيه والجزء الاكبر ايضا
يتبع الى وكاله غوس وتشغيل اللاجئين تم
تدميرها وقصفها
بالكامل مناطق مربعات سكنيه بالكامل تم
قصفها وتم نحوها عن الوجود جهاد ابو شنب
لصالح قناه الجزيره
غزه